hey everyone I'd like to thank you all
for commenting and voting in my last
video I had over 1,100 comments in less
than a week which is pretty amazing I
look through the comment section and I
checked to see which comments had the
most thumbs up and the one with the
highest rating was this comment here
that had 88 votes and basically said to
do both of them now I would like to do
both but I did ask which tutorial would
be next because I don't want to put two
of them in one video so the next highest
rated comment was this one here that had
81 votes and basically said to do the
ninja star the double ninja star and I
think most people agree because I also
put a poll up and 66% of people out of
about 500 votes want to see the ninja
star the same thing with my facebook
wall so I think most people really want
to see the tutorial for the dist:8 the
double interlocked single-sided
transforming a pointed ninja star I
think we're just gonna go with double
ninja star instead I apologize for those
who really wanted to see the heart in
time for Valentine's Day especially this
guy I hope you can find another gift and
I would like to do a tutorial sometime
in the near future for this tutorial we
need to know how to make two single
sided ninja stars now I do have a
tutorial for this but I'm gonna show you
a better way to do it you're going to
need one piece of printer paper if you'd
like to use one color if you want to use
two colors like the one I have here then
you're going to need two sheets we need
to start out with two halves of a letter
sized paper since I'm using two
different colors I'm going to take two
full-sized sheets
fold them both in half and then cut them
or tear them along this line here if
you're using one color then you only
need to do it for one sheet take both of
the halves now and you're going to hold
them both horizontally then take the top
end fold it down to the bottom end make
a crease along the top do the same for
the other sheet now what I like to do is
to run my fingernail a few times against
the top of that crease and then hold
both of the edges facing downwards like
this and then you could just tear them
in half
now we've split the paper into quarters
and we only need two of them in order to
make one ninja star the ninja star
pieces are made the exact same way they
all look like the letter Z I'm going to
go through with you how to make two of
them to make one ninja star and then you
can make the other two to make the
second ninja star hold both of the
pieces horizontally like this and take
the top end of the paper and fold it
down to the bottom end of the paper once
you have the edges neatly aligned then
make a crease along the top then we
could take the left side of the paper
and fold it across to the right side so
once the edges are neatly lined up might
need to just round it off here and make
a crease on the left now you can open it
up and you'll see we have this halfway
point I'm going to make a mark there so
you can see it a little easier now what
we're going to do is we're going to take
the top edge here and fold it down onto
that halfway point just like this once
you've lined it up make a crease on the
outside then we're going to take the
left side here and fold this bottom edge
up onto that mid line just like this
make a crease on the outside now what we
could do is flip the piece of paper over
and you'll see we have the top edge and
the bottom edge here and we're going to
fold the top edge right on to this edge
of the paper here so fold it all the way
down just like that and then make a
crease now you could take the bottom
edge and fold it up onto that edge there
and then make another crease you should
have something that looks like this now
we're going to take the upper right
corner and fold it down to the lower
left corner take the upper right corner
fold it down just like that and make a
crease now we could take the lower left
corner and fold it up to the upper right
corner here so just fold it like this
and make a crease on the outside and
there you go that's how to make one of
the pieces it's not so bad so then you
can fold the top down and then you can
fold the little bottom triangle up like
this so now you should have something
like this and we're going to do the same
for the other piece of paper take the
top end fold it down to the bottom end
fold the paper in half like this make a
crease open it right side goes down on
to that midline left side goes up flip
it over top goes down the bottom goes up
and then the same thing upper right
corner down to the lower left corner
bottom left corner to the upper right
corner
fold them both inwards and there you go
now you have two pieces now I'll show
you how to interlock the two pieces
together in order to get your ninja star
remember the pieces are exactly the same
and they look like the letter Z also
make sure that these little points or
tips are facing towards you I think some
people had a little bit of trouble in my
other tutorial because the paper was
twice as thick and I also went a little
bit quickly so I'll take it nice and
slow you're going to take the right
piece and you're going to turn it to the
left like this until this little edge
here is horizontal and pointed to the
left just like that then you're going to
put the red piece on top of the blue
piece now you'll see in the middle you
have what looks like an X formed by the
two pieces we're going to start with any
one of these flaps it doesn't matter so
I'm going to take this flap here and
fold it inwards to the middle of the two
pieces so take this and fold it in just
like that right on top of the red piece
then we're going to go in a clockwise
direction so just take the next piece
and fold it on top of the first piece
then we can go that this piece now it's
easier to make sure that these pieces
are a little curved or bent like this so
just bend them and put it on top it's
just like that so we have one two three
we're going to take the last piece and
you also want to make sure that it's
curved or bent like this then you're
going to put it over the third piece and
underneath the first piece into this
little pocket right there so you want to
fold it like this put it over the third
piece and underneath the first piece
right in that little pocket then you
could push it all the way in and make
sure everything is nice and flat by
pushing down on it and there you go it
shouldn't be that bad here's a ninja
star now that you know how to interlock
the two pieces together to get the ninja
stars it should be pretty easy for you
to interlock two of the stars together
in order to get the double ninja star
if you take a look at the ninja star
you'll see that it has this little
sleeve on the back and it's the sleeves
of the ninja stars that allow two of
them to interlock together so we're
going to take a blue piece from the left
ninja star and a red piece from the
right ninja star it doesn't really
matter you can use the same color it's
just easier to see this way now we're
going to flip the piece on the right
upside down and you'll see now these
flaps or tips are facing downwards away
from us now we could put the red piece
on top of the blue piece just like this
and you'll see that these edges touch
each other or a line just like that and
it almost looks like an eight now I want
you to ignore this red piece just
pretend it's not there and then take the
other red piece that normally interlocks
with the blue piece and do the same
thing that I just showed you put it on
top of the blue piece and then we're
going to just interlock these two pieces
together like we normally would so fold
the blue piece in there's the first flap
second flap here's the third one just
make sure that it's curved and fold it
over the red piece and then the last one
again make sure that it's curved fold it
over the third piece and underneath the
first piece just like that so there you
go you have the first ninja star re
interlocked and you'll see if you flip
it over that you have this piece kind of
underneath that little sleeve so now you
can hold this piece like this with these
two flaps facing towards you and then
take the other piece and do the same
thing position it directly over this
blue piece just like that so now you'll
see you have a cross in the middle and
then the same thing take the red piece
now and fold it in do the same thing
we're going to fold in a clockwise
direction so do this one next then you
could fold this red piece
I'd have to shift it around a little bit
and then you take the last blue piece
round it off going to do over the third
piece and underneath the first piece
just like that so just tuck it in like
that and there you go
you have the double ninja star now to
kind of transform it what you want to do
is to twist the top star clockwise like
that and you'll see they'll kind of a
line you can see the other one from
behind but all you need to do now is to
just twist it counterclockwise like that
and you have the double ninja star
thanks for watching my tutorial for the
double ninja stars I hope that you guys
enjoyed it if you did like the video be
sure to click the thumbs up or like
button down below and if you're not
subscribed already click the silver
subscribe button above now I did kind of
reteach the single-sided ninja star
tutorials and there's a few reasons why
I did that one all you need is one piece
of printer paper in order to make two of
the stars to the other ninja star is a
little bit thicker and harder to
interlock for if you come across this
tutorial first then you don't need to
watch another video in order to make the
double ninja star and three I went
through how to do the double ninja star
super slow so you shouldn't get confused
[Music]